when you work for the SCP Foundation One
certainty is that nothing no turn of
events no scenario is ever really
unexpected no matter how unlikely
something may appear chances are it
usually happens and if it doesn't happen
here then in an infinite Multiverse of
Alternatives everything that can
possibly happen is statistically likely
to we've covered a few of these
alternate eventualities before a number
of which revolve around the differing
events in the long life of one
particular anomaly
scp-076-2 better known as able in our
home Universe much like he is and many
others Abel is considered to be a
near-perfect warrior his body covered in
tattoos of occult symbols and demonic
faces is capable of withstanding vast
amounts of physical damage Abel can
easily take hits from the most powerful
Conventional Weapons mankind has to
offer and survived with little more than
a scratch what's more you can draw an
endless supply of black bladed weapons
from a tiny pocket Dimension and on top
of all of that even in the event that
he's bested in combat Abel's body will
rapidly disintegrate only to reform
within a large Stone Cube known as
scp-076-1 like most of us Abel has a
number of almost identical counterparts
that exist across the various worlds of
the Multiverse one of them once had the
opportunity to reconcile with his
brother Kane the man seemingly
responsible for Abel's endless life of
Bloodshed and once the two brothers had
made peace they could rest In Another
Universe Abel worked directly with the
SCP Foundation as part of a mobile task
force until they turned on him this
unfurled a chain of events so
cataclysmic that the entire world
suffered the consequences this alternate
Abel went on a Warpath against the
foundation ultimately using scp-94 18
the Clockworks to refine his destructive
anomalous abilities this allowed him to
unleash chaos slaughtering all of
humanity in an omnicide that wiped the
world clean of all other life leaving
Abel alone in a dead world and then
there was this version of The Immortal
Warrior far from the Clockworks enhanced
conqueror that his alternate universe
counterpart was this able had long since
been removed as a member of MTF omega-7
and was gradually reconstituting his
body within
scp-076-1 his most recent defeat had
enraged the warrior and he had vowed to
once again be free although unbeknownst
to him what set this particular version
of Abel apart from his other variants
was the fact that he would soon
encounter a certain other anomaly
something that when wielded by
scp-076-2 had the potential to
completely Rob him of all his centuries
worth of fighting ability and replace it
with an embarrassment that would last
for centuries more but first a quick
history lesson much like it had been in
our universe this particular anomalous
object had been recovered by the
foundation after it made its way into
the hands of an unwitting police officer
the item in question was scp-572 a
particularly unique Katana unique in
that it was utterly useless for fighting
with and caused more harm to the person
wielding it than whoever they were
trying to use it against in this
universe the sword had already changed
hands a number of times when police were
called to the home of one clearance
Clancy clancerson he drew scp-572 in
defense and screamed at the officers
that he would quote take their heads and
with it their power the cops had been
sent over to arrest Clancy for violent
and disorderly Behavior were less than
threatened to see their suspect who was
somewhat out of shape coming at them
with a weapon no sharper than a butter
knife after pacifying Clancy with tasers
and beanbag rounds from 12 gauge shotgun
the police retrieved scp-572 and then it
was acquired by a foundation operative
this all played out almost the exact
same way in our universe however in this
version of events there was one key
difference as previously mentioned
scp-572 was an unremarkable sword but it
had something of a storied past passing
from one unfortunate user to the next
and just as it was recovered from
Clancy's house and ended up in
Foundation hands one of those former
owners had just been about to reclaim
the fabled weapon for himself meanwhile
back in this containment chamber deep
under the ocean still trapped in the
stone Cube he reanimated within Abel was
lost in a dream to any other person
falling asleep to see subconscious
visions of so much Carnage would be
horrifying they would call it a
nightmare but to Abel this might have
been one of the sweetest dreams that he
had ever experienced all around him was
a world on fire having returned to life
once again able at last vested his
captors at the SCP Foundation in his
dream he traveled the world visiting
every Foundation facility one by one and
reducing them to Rubble without leaving
a single Survivor then once the work was
done he turned his barbaricism towards
the wider world and began slaughtering
Humanity in droves perhaps some distant
Cosmic Echo had reached out across the
Multiverse a fragment of the life of a
more refined version of himself had
slipped into Abel's subconsciousness
making him dream that he too was the
omnicidal Conqueror that his other self
was seeing such Devastation in his own
wake made this version of able eager to
wake up to revive once more and set
about making this delightful dream of
Destruction a deadly reality it was
while Abel was dreaming picturing
himself cutting down all who dare to
pose him that something strange seemed
to happen he had a visitor not a visitor
to his containment chamber mind you
there was no one beyond the confines of
scp-076-1 except the security team that
normally kept the stone Cube under arm
surveillance no this visitor appeared
somewhere else inside Abel's mind
approaching him as he slept within the
Warriors slumbering fantasy he was
climbing up a mountain of skulls after
having slaughtered Millions if not
billions already but as he reached the
top of the pile of bones and looked out
over the horizon Abel could see that the
world Beyond was still living there were
just as many people alive perhaps even
more that he'd already killed his work
was not yet done in fact it seemed that
despite all the lives The Immortal Mad
Men had already claimed he had barely
even begun
a voice studded did you really think you
could do it alone even though this was a
dream Abel could feel the presence of
another he pulled one of the is Obsidian
edged weapons from thin air and swiped
in the direction The Voice had come from
hitting nothing the blade in his hands
seemed to change its dark metal
transforming from solid to liquid coming
apart in his hands able sword melted
like candle wax under a hot flame
reduced to nothing in seconds you can't
do it the voice whispered you aren't
strong enough but I can help with that
pulling out another weapon a two-handed
ax this time Abel looked around him
trying to locate the source of the
taunting noise only a coward relies on
cheap tricks and Illusions he growled
angrily show yourself come forward and
be slain are you a worthy opponent are
you worth your time are you the voice
Justin we shall see Abel yelled behind
him a cloak figure silently appeared
they looked to be adorned in a robe that
whipped in the biting cold wind yet
their garments weren't made of any
fabric instead they wore a robe made out
of Your Shadow their clothes and body
comprised of the same thing though they
lacked any tangible solid matter it
didn't stop Abel from spinning around
swinging his heavy ax in the figure's
direction before the blade of the weapon
was even halfway through the air it had
already started to become liquid just
like the swords had earlier by the time
it came down to strike at the shadowy
visitor what had once been an ax was
just a flick of melted black metal
passing through the intangible Specter
as Abel found himself once again unarmed
straighten he demanded number one to
back away from a fight even when his
weapons were seemingly failing him tell
me who you are I would like to know my
adversary's name before I end your
worthless life I am not here to fight
you the figure replied calmly I'm here
to offer you the key to your Victory
able what key the warrior sneered what
could you possibly give me exactly what
you need to finish it the shadow replied
drawing something from a sheath on its
belt and holding it Aloft a weapon that
will allow you to become the Conqueror
you long to be Ava looked at the object
in the figures outstretched hand a
katana or at least the shadowy Vestige
of one a sword he sneered what use do I
have for a sword I can conjure all the
blades I needed will to demonstrate able
pulled one of his own black blades but
yet again it began to melt away your
weapons have served you well but they
are disposable the shadow explained a
true warrior deserves a sword worthy of
his fighting prowess I have killed
scores of men throughout the ages The
Immortal Warrior retorted and I never
needed any special sword to do that and
that is why no matter how many you
killed you will always be beaten in his
dream Mabel paused a moment looking at
the katana and considering then he
reached his hand out to grip the shadowy
hilt in that same Split Second
scp-076-2 awoke once again from a
slumber and broke free of the stone Cube
encasing him as he killed his way
through the foundation Personnel in the
facility housing
scp-076-1 Abel had only one thought in
his mind he needed that sword you see
what the immortal Maniac was
unfortunately totally unaware of was the
interesting effect
scp-572 could have on people as well as
being a totally useless sword anyone who
picked it up will instantly believe the
katana of apparent invincibility to be
an all-powerful weapon of ancient legend
despite the sword being crudely made
blunt and generally unfit for any use
the wielder will maintain the belief
that it not only has perfect balance and
cutting power but that the sword has
also imbued them with unparalleled
strength and invincibility to damage and
now either through the sword itself
extending this Cognito hazardous
influence into Able's dream or by the
interference of some unknown trickery
one of the most dangerous anomalous
killers in the world was making a
beeline straight for
scp-572 and he wasn't the only one
either at a previous point in time a man
by the name of Zack had purchased
scp-572 on eBay but it was far more than
just an oddity to it he wasn't looking
to start a sword collection as a child
he had been obsessed with comic book
superheroes and when Zach bought that
Katana he intended to use the blade to
dispense of vigilant empty Justice
against those who prayed on the innocent
and even before he held it in his hands
Zach II felt the anomalous pull of the
katana knowing in his heart it was the
perfect weapon to transform him into a
hero of course he had quickly been
disproven when on his first night of
crime fighting Zach had been hit by a
midsize sedan in a multi-story parking
lot and suffered a concussion sent to
the hospital and then charged with
attempted assault Zack had long since
lost any and all interest in ever
donning his costume comprised of hockey
pads in the ski mask or picking up the
sword ever again but as time had gone on
that old familiar pole had started to
gnaw at Zach urging him to get back in
the superhero game forgetting how poorly
that had worked out for him last time
one problem still stood in his way
though he needed his trusty sword back
of course in the time since he'd hung up
his hero outfit Clancy had gotten his
hands on
scp-572 and then right before his Zach
could steal it back the foundation had
taken it it had taken him months of
preparation he'd sneakily made dealings
with a janitor that worked at one of the
foundation sites Zach had bribed the man
a lot of money in exchange for his key
card in uniform even having to take out
a second mortgage on his apartment to
meet the frankly extortionate amount the
janitor asked for but it would be worth
the cost Zack told himself if it
reunited him with his trustee Katana
then it would be worth it only then
would he once again be a full hero
shuffling through the facility Zack
dragged a mop over the floor leaving a
sign to warn the slippery Hazard he
whistled to himself trying to act as
casually as possible not realizing that
he was slightly overselling it once he
was certain the coast was clear he made
his move
scp-572 was locked in a secure deposit
box within site 19's high value item
storage facility right where he had been
cleaning he began searching through the
various anomalous Oddities kept there
until he saw it the Box containing his
coveted sword all his effort in
infiltrating the foundation had finally
paid off it was all leading to this his
comeback in crime fighting it was at
this precise moment that Abel came
bursting through a nearby door
completely befuddled Zach quickly found
himself thrown to one side by the much
stronger man out of my way weakling Abel
roared before turning to face the
deposit box holding scp-572 gripping the
Box able used his superhuman strength to
tear it open as though the container was
made from cardboard there it was stored
safely within was the weapon he had been
seeking the same all-powerful sword from
his vision at last he declared reaching
for the hilt this sword belongs to me
the second that Abel hoisted it into the
air he felt a human weight dashed
towards him only to shrug it off as it
made impact Zach tumbled to the floor
winded as Abel barely flinched at the
attempted tackle you fool he roared you
dare come at me you'll be the first to
fall to my new Blade the first of this
pathetic world of unworthy opponents to
die in my Conquest Zack frighteningly
raised his arms in an attempt to Shield
himself when Abel raised the sword
menacingly above his head the Mortal man
knew what the sword was capable of or so
he thought as Abel brought the blade
swiping downwards its true
ineffectiveness as a melee weapon was on
full display
scp-572's dull poorly balanced blade
barely graze Zack's arms as he protected
his face in fact beyond the initial SWAT
it barely hurt I I don't understand
cable stammer looking at the katana in
confusion this is meant to be a warrior
blade a weapon of Champions and
conquerors yeah that's what I was
thinking Zach replied also suffering
from scp-572's Cognito hazardous effect
he fully expected to die a second ago
slain by the very weapon he had been
hoping to reclaim still maybe it's just
because it's your first go I could show
you how to silence I will not fall for
that Abel interrupted let me see here
maybe the angle was off or how about I
use both hands here let me just once
again Abel hoisted the weapon this time
with both hands tightly gripping the
blade intending to bring it slashing
down in a big swing like a Woodsman
cleaving a log into unfortunately as he
raised the sword the blade caught an
exposed light fixture above Sparks burst
from the ceiling as an electrical
current shot through the metal and gave
Abel a nasty shock oh God
the meaning of this shouted in
frustration I've been alive for
centuries killed thousands upon
thousands of men since the dawn of
civilization why can't I use this sword
well performance issues for a guy your
age hardly an uncommon problem Zach
joked both turned at the sound of a door
kicked open the clump of heavy boots on
the ground is a foundation security team
burst in scp-076
Commander stopped then shout wait that's
not one of his regular swords is it sir
um that's uh
one of the officers paused inside I
think that's
scp-572 attack me Abel yelled at the
foundation officers pointing the dull
tip of the katana at them if you dare
but now I will the greatest blade known
to the universe you will all fall in a
single stroke of my new weapon and once
you have fallen so shall the world
scp-076-2 Abel look just put the thing
down the commander urged uh trust me
you'll thank yourself
your pathetic fools are so afraid of the
chaos I will unleash the warrior
declared such unworthy opponents okay
I've seen enough the security
Commander's side deadly force authorized
light em up boys on the Commander's
signal a hail of gunfire erupted bullets
raining down unable he slashed scp-572
through the air certain that what he
thought was a mighty sword could easily
cut through the oncoming bullets of
course that may have been true if
scp-572's only real power was not having
any power at all each shot struck able
Center Mass barely damaging him given
his body's natural resilience to harm
particularly from such Small Arms fire
although he didn't find it any less
annoying that he couldn't seem to
properly wield his new Katana oh are you
kidding me he have to himself what is
with me today can't get the hang of this
thing come on man but still a sword the
weapon that would allow me to conquer
this whole world but if I can just get
the swing right calmly knowing that the
weapon itself posed no threat even in
the hands of an immortal mass murderer
the security team moved in to apprehend
Abel before they could take the katana
from his hands he dashed towards them
swiping the sword back and forth hoping
to at least hit someone to get the ball
rolling on his omnicidal Rampage instead
thanks to the influence of scp-572 he
miscalculated took a wrong step and
slipped over on a patch of freshly
mopped tile Landing in a heap next to a
wet floor sign the security Team all
winced feeling the second hand
embarrassment practically radiating off
of Abel as the ancient anomalous Warrior
lay on the floor after a spectacular all
then one by one they all burst out into
uncontrollable fits of laughter but
while they were distracted they were
completely oblivious to Zach who emerged
from his hiding place and picked scp-572
up off the floor he breathed to cyber
Leaf reunited with his prized weapon
having forgotten the severe injury it
caused him last time you able wheezed
still lying in a puddle of mop water who
are you Zach gave a slight smile
unzipping the janitors overalls he had
on to reveal a set of hockey pads
underneath he slipped a ski mask over
his face before turning back to Abel and
replying in his most epic voice I'm
captain Katana unfortunately his return
to crime fighting would be as
short-lived as Abel's own turn with
scp-572 as Captain Katana found himself
hit by a bus on his way home after
trying to use the katana of apparent
invincibility to cut set bus in half
down the middle and failing in a rather
painful fashion wanted anomaly of your
own check out
www.scpswag.com for high quality SCP
merch now go and check out is scp-572
the most dangerous weapon ever and
scp-076 able vs chainsaw man who has the
most lethal weapon to get your weapon
fanatic fix